Fox Sports and Sports Illustrated hybrid
if you will
college football man and maven good to
see you sir thanks for coming in pre
good to be here so what in the world is
going on at Ole Miss where did can you
walk us through what happened to Hugh
Freeze yeah so the sound of the scandal
with the NCAA that was already dirty and
grimy and Ole Miss was in the thick of
it and Ole Miss administration had
really backed him even though a lot of
people thought they wouldn't to this
degree
but then this took another turn so
what's the crazy part about this is
former Ole Miss head coach Houston Nutt
who is the guy that Freeze replaced had
gone to and ten and kind of left the
place a mess he was not happy with how
he had been portrayed in the media and
in the wake of this the NCAA
investigation and Houston Houston Nutt
last week brought brought a lawsuit
against Ole Miss you freeze for
basically smearing him and and trying to
put all the blame or a lot of the blame
on on him for this scandal and what's
come in the wake of this was in
discovery they had gotten some phone
records and a lot of the phone record
calls were redacted but one there was a
mystery number that had not been
redacted and it turned out that was to
an escort service it was for one minute
unbelievable but then when after Hugh
Freeze is denials Ole Miss had
proactively I actually things probably
they said practically I think it's
really more reactive Lee had looked into
other calls Hugh Freeze had made and
found what they said with a disturbing
pattern when the ad was asked about if
this was more escort services he really
declined to elaborate but it obviously
something of that nature and that's the
end of that so maybe those were part of
it any speculation and what the redacted
numbers were was out could those have
been that or were they members of the
media that he well they already had I
was trying to find there was already the
members of the media I mean look I was
one of myself there was a couple of
years PN reporters you get calls from I
know you're not up about revealing
sources but did you get calls from old
myths phone numbers to say hey this is
Houston Nutt not us I know you are to
that campaign you know what had happened
in my specific case was I had reached
out to them
after one of my old colleagues Pat 40 I
think had broken news that right before
signing to a couple of years ago that
the NCAA was going to come down on Ole
Miss now we didn't know how hard I had
called Ole Miss a couple of people
misses try to find out more details it's
you know typically what reporters do now
what I had reported as it related to
that lawsuit which is to me is kinda
interesting how they framed it because
in our story at foxsports.com it was
that the bulk of the sanctions were not
the majority of the sanctions were not
related to Hugh Freeze and that's
actually accurate because when you
consider it was related to women's
basketball also women's track but also
some from Houston Nutt so the number of
was way more than fifty percent that was
against other but you know that was
included and there was a lot of it and
it turned out you know it was like they
seemed have been going for that they got
a way bigger golden goose if you're
trying to give Hugh Freeze has come up
and say hey we just want an apology
they got more than that they got you
fries a scalp with this in a ugly ugly
scandal no question about that let's get
some more insider information in the
Honda inside a report from Fox Sports
Sports Illustrated Bruce Feldman did the
Laremy Tunsil draft night playing to
this at all it did a little bit in this
regard so as you remember you know that
thing blows up with the bong and the gas
mask and then by the way have you ever
said those words before into a
microphone or in a conversation on gas
man that thing blows up with the I'm not
that smart I don't have 50 on Friday
more okay um so when that happened also
he had a press conference afterwards out
of the Instagram accounts that went back
and forth with a member of the staff
about hey mom needs to get pay her light
bill and I need money for rent yeah look
you know if you were I basically talked
for a living you way more than me we're
in this setting on the biggest night of
your life and trying to explain this I'm
not sure how well we'd have handled it
sure he threw some stuff out there like
it was almost like gasoline on the
grease fire and that made it worse than
what that did was it gave the n-c-a-a
more time to go dig back into the old
Miss a legal benefits scandal
so that gave it more wet a more weight
then all of a sudden you obviously had
the Houston not lawsuit that gave the
phone records part of it to me what's
what's very curious about this is so
when Ole Miss brass went with went
through this with Hugh Freeze he could
have said you know okay this number this
is my wife's number this is my daughter
some of this milder daughters number
that one mystery number you know I think
he could have said yeah that's my Aunt
Sally in Florida and they might have you
know took the magic marker and or the
you know black pen and gone right
through it and maybe this doesn't get
out I don't know if there would have
been you know if they would have done
their due diligence and go hey we're
going to double check on you freeze
because some of this stuff may you know
you know we're sticking our neck out for
him did we have we ever found out who
did this to Tunsil that's totally never
been answered yeah any any certainty
career the one thing I remember here in
a while back was that it was a runner
from another agency right that had kind
of gotten gotten sideways there that's
never like the Dolphins have never
really you know hammered that thing
through publicly Ole Miss the NCAA I
mean isn't this yeah what I met that
could be under NCAA purview and they're
not on the illegal Bennis because once
you're out of the NCAA's jurisdiction
then you know it's not Reggie Bush needs
to talk to you know anybody who goes on
talking about the Ole Miss football
program giving an illegal benefit to
somebody well that's still in the
crosshairs I mean they're going to have
to you know what's what's going to be
interesting now is in a month or two
probably either September October when
they are in the you know meeting with
the Committee on Infractions explain
this they had backed you freeze up
strong now do they go well you know
we're going to maybe take a little more
of a look and try to pawn it off on Hugh
Freeze a little more of the
responsibility say hey we've cleaned up
going forward because they have solve
section one this coming season for a
postseason ban and some scholarships
that probably wouldn't be enough for the
NCAA I'm almost positive if you freeze
was still there now Hugh Freeze is
obviously not going to be the head coach
there the question is they made a point
of saying that he was fired for
something that was completely unrelated
to the NCAA mess so you said that
publicly how did the NCAA view that did
they just kind of go hey you're lost
we're still going
after you hard Bruce Feldman here in the
Honda inside a report Brockman let's
turn the page now as to who could be
next in at Ole Miss what are the sites
that related to the Ole Miss football
that Lane defense Twitter handle
followed just this very day in the wake
of the news out of Mississippi yeah not
that long ago Lane Kiffin little active
on the Twitter followed Ole Miss Inc om
rebel nation Ole Miss football Ole Miss
picks and Houston Nutt is this at all
possible that kiffin could get back in
the SEC that Ole Miss had older than
that that this is a marriage as wildly
entertaining as that would be have it's
having back in the SEC in the SEC West
no less you know around round Nick
Saban's program there's almost no chance
there is no chance of that happening for
not even a Dumb and Dumber chance no
because they can't touch anybody they're
going to be coming out of an NCAA mess
they cannot touch anybody who has any
kind of NCAA baggage they also probably
don't need anybody who has any kind of
personal baggage or seems like could be
a character risk beyond that his defense
coordinator his brother Chris Kiffin was
probably the best recruiter on on Ole
Miss a staff under Hugh Freeze and Chris
was it was you know in on some of the
NCAA violations like he's mentioned in
some of this so I just could never see a
whole miss going as much entertainment
value as there probably would be in that
I just couldn't see it now maybe Lane
wins big at FAU and can get a power five
job I just don't see if an Ole Miss
although it's probably the one school
that couldn't touch it so what about ole
Miss's options now who's out there
realistically I notice people thrown out
yeah they got a call Chip Kelly yeah so
they can have Chip Kelly laugh in their
face she probably would have touched Ole
Miss without this stuff so now all of a
sudden and there's some keep in mind you
know
Tennessee's head coaches on the hotseat
Texas A&M coaches definitely on the hot
seat because his ad is publicly said so
those are bigger jobs with better
facilities way better history and way
better resources and they don't have
potentially you know multiple season
postseason banner becomes that and
certainly probation and NCAA scholarship
hits I think realistically
what they're looking at is the guy they
made as their interim Matt Luke he is a
former Ole Miss walk-on Center who is a
David Cutcliffe guy which which carries
some clout because David Cutcliffe has a
high integrity guy everybody knows Matt
Luke says that I mean I would I would
say that as well
he's the interim guy I'm not sure like
if he has a decent year this year I mean
and goes six and six seven and five and
they have pretty good players they have
a really good young quarterback in shape
Patterson I think that would convince
some people to go yo let's give Matt a
chance to push through this because
realistically he may be as good option
as we have otherwise I think you're
you're probably looking at the head
coach at Troy a guy and Neal Brown maybe
Frank Wilson who was a former Ole Miss
assistant who's a UTSA Texas San Antonio
guys like that it's you're not going to
see somebody you know I like who has a
big job now and go okay let me jump into
the SEC I mean remember ole Miss's
facilities have been upgraded their
stadium is still one of the lesser
stadiums there and there are a lot of
people you talk to in coaching Google
you know what the only time anybody's
ever really been able to win and get
much traction there
they've basically had to cheat to do it
it's Bruce Feldman here on the Rich
Eisen show and the Honda insider report
again brought to you by the 2017 Honda
Accord it's stylish spacious and
comfortable and right now you could get
a great deal at the Honda some abrasion
sales event but you better hurry because
like training camp it is going to be all
over soon if I can get you to stay one
more segment I'd like to talk about a
couple items with you first of all what
appears to be something that is new and
perhaps going to be repeated in our
business which is removing writers from
sports websites for video to take the
written word out and say everything is
now going to be video because that's
what assumed is the 21st century aspect
of our business and also the concept
that Sam Donald would actually stay at
USC because he doesn't want to play for
the Jets that has been a huge topic of
conversation in the National Football
League that's Bruce Feldman will talk
about those subjects well Rob Corddry is
waiting in the wings from ballers and
ours three we're back with more in a
moment
Fox Sports & Sports Illustrated's Bruce
Feldman here on the show you are now a
hybrid as they say in the business
you used to be Fox Sports writing and
television on-air reporting now you are
Fox Sports honor television on air
during games right through the sidelines
and writing for Sports Illustrated so
congratulations on being able to land in
a prestigious spot like Sports
Illustrated what are you and your
brethren scribes in the business talking
about now that Fox Sports went in the
way that apparently Vice sports just did
the same thing laying off all of their
riders and going just straight video now
in the 21st century yeah it's been an
ugly offseason for my colleagues who
cover college sports you just kind of
massive layoffs and mostly to the
reporting side if you look I think they
lay it off like 75% of their college
writers reporters si where I landed laid
off you know some of my friends ended up
you know getting getting whacked there
and you know as relates to Fox
sports.com they had a big philosophical
shift that I think really started to
kind of get into the staff like back in
January now I wasn't there physically
for that meeting I didn't really know a
ton about what was going on but my
contract was coming up at the end of
April and I was really excited about the
direction of like it's weird I kind of
ended up doing sideline reporting two
years ago and just kind of got thrown
into it and loved doing it and it's
worked out really well and I got bumped
up a crew to work with Joe Davis and
Brady Quinn and I'm fired up about that
this season but in terms of the writing
side it's just like it took me a while
for the to understand wait a minute
there's gonna be actually no written
content it's just going to videos it's I
don't get I mean I don't get it yeah I
think what's happening is a lot of
people do not know like because of our
phones I don't surf and I don't surf the
web anymore I find what I find on
Twitter you know I do have some
bookmarks on my computer but I'm not
sure how many people ever were surfing
to foxsports.com no I but I mean there's
it's the Internet so there's enough
space you know it's not as if it is a
confined actual
the screen cannot take more than just
what's on it of course it can you scroll
down but there's got to be some parts
where somebody wants to read something
deeper than what an analyst is saying on
this on camera there's more than just
then three minutes of consumable
bite-sized conversation or argument yeah
I think also from a layer to this is if
you don't have reporters you know when
some story breaks whether it's Hugh
Freeze getting fired or Bob Stoops
retiring and Lincoln rally taking over
at least college football related or you
know trade deadline stuff or whatever as
well as other sports where are the
people who are on the grass on the
ground doing that because a lot of the
people were just talking about it
they are probably searching the web to
get their Intel maybe some of them are
plugged in but I'm not sure how many of
them because you know if you're one of
the people who's kind of a talking head
on one of those debate shows you're
talking about seven different sports
hopefully or a bunch of different stuff
well I mean just in the last segment in
our insider report you you gave the four
one one best you can in a any thirty to
forty five second you know turn at the
mic about what happened at Ole Miss but
this is this this needs like a multi
paragraph deep dive to actually explain
I only have two minutes left that said
to turn the pay I want to ask you about
the conversation here in Los Angeles
that Sam Donald might stay at USC
because he sees potentially the clouds
forming with a Jets tank job and the NFL
and he doesn't want any piece of that
well I really think it really has to do
with the Jets as much as I'm sure Daniel
Jeremiah would like to needle you who
but I I don't think it has to do with
the Jets about in early May
there's pac-12 meetings I talked to clay
Helton the coach at USC and he just said
kind of matter-of-factly a lot of people
were just assuming Sam's going to leave
you know he hasn't even started a full
year us he basically started yeah I
missed the first month of the season he
hasn't played that much football by the
way the reason why he wasn't a huge
recruit like a five-star guy is because
he missed most of his junior year to
doesn't played that much football he
grew up as a huge USC fan where were
Matt Leinart jersey war Reggie Bush's
Jersey everything he's a Southern
California kid I think he genuinely
wants to embrace everything that's going
on
I'm not saying there's no chance you
know he doesn't come out I don't think
it has anything to do I don't want to go
to the Jets or I don't I don't think I
mean he's a really competitive kid I'd
actually be surprised if there was any
place in his head where he'd go oh I'm
going to stay because I don't want to go
there
I think it really more has to do with
hey I finally get to be the quarterback
at my dream school and we're building up
now this is a program that's now coming
out of the sanctions remember like eight
months ago everybody was trying to fire
clay Helton after the first month of the
season
now all the sudden people are buying in
I think they're only going to get better
but he's got a rebuilt offensive line
you got pretty much all new receivers
except one so I think he's really ready
to embrace this and see where it goes
thanks for coming on really appreciate
it we'll have you back on later in a
next month we'll talk deep deeper and
put every a time just down the road I
appreciate that that's Bruce development
of Fox Sports and Sports Illustrated the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on radio stations across the country and
audience if you liked that video be sure
to download our app and I'll be sure to
help the NFL figure out what it catches